- We appreciate your making
time in the middle of your day.
This is the Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
at the Whitney Humanity Center at Yale.
The title of the series is
The Value of Marx's Capital.
In there somewhere is
the idea that the people
who are presenting will
be rethinking the value
or revaluing different
parts of Capital Volume one,
based on their own work, based
on the needs of the moment.
The series is a companion
to an undergraduate seminar at Yale
and also goes along with
the work that I'm doing
as a co-editor, but
really that the translator
of a new English edition
of "Capital Volume One",
my colleague Paul Reitter at OSU is doing
to bring out a lot of the values
that got hidden in the older translation.
So the new translation
of Capital Volume One,
translated by Paul Reitter should be out
in a couple of years with Princeton.
So Paul is here and he's
gonna help me discuss.
We need to thank a few
people first of all,
the Franke family who make
these lectures possible,
specifically Richard and Barbara Franke,
who endow these lectures
to present important topics
of the humanities to a
wide n general audience.
I wanna thank Alice Kaplan,
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center.
Who's beginning to do amazing things
in her new position there.
Sandra Malan-Bowles
who allowed this to happen
through all of her work.
Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen who's
the graduate assistant
and Audrey Leak, undergraduate assistant
running the tech.
What we're gonna do is have a presentation
which will be interactive with our guest,
Professor Lucia Pradella
from King's College London.
After that, students in the
seminar will get a chance
to ask questions first
and to make their comments
so they will put their comments
and questions in the chat,
and then we'll give them first dibs.
After that, anyone else who's in the room
who wants to ask questions,
I'll ask you to hold your
questions until it's Q&A time
otherwise they get lost in the queue,
and I'm not nearly adept enough
to keep that all in order.
So I'll signal you, you can
write down your questions
on a pad or on your screen somehow,
and then you can post
them and we'll get to you
and hopefully we'll get to everyone.
Okay, so I wanna start as
I've been starting these
with a quote from the author,
and this is it, it's
provocative and I think true.
Quote, Marx was among the
first European intellectuals
who supported the
struggles of the colonized.
Marx's learning from the South,
made a difference in his understanding
of global development and global history.
Not only did Marx become
aware of the strength
of the Asian economies,
he also denied the inevitability
of colonialism in China.
Looking at China's living
tradition of peasant revolts,
he saw the need for a national revolution
that could spark and link up
with a social revolution in Europe.
Here's the peak of this thought.
Colonized peoples thus
appeared as subjects
not only of their own history,
but also crucially of world politics.
This is aligned from an article
by Professor Lucia Pradella
who has spent a lot of time
reconstructing Marx's views
about what seemed to be
marginal in a European theory.
It turns out to be a global theory
and a lot of what has been called marginal
is really central for Marx and
has force in its own right.
Lucia Pradella who is with us today
is a senior lecturer in
International and Political Economy
at King's College London.
She has a PhD from the
University of Naples
and Donaghy DS in Nanterre.
She collaborated on the historical
critical edition of Marx
and angles complete works in German,
which is a high distinction.
And she's written two books on "Capital".
The second book, I'll mention the title,
"Globalization and the
Critique of Political Economy,”
"New Insights from Marx's Writings"
fits right into our topic,
the Value of Marx's Writings.
She is discovering new value
in the text all the time.
She works on the
understanding of capitalist,
globalization of colonialism
and anti-colonial resistance
in light of Marx's still
unpublished notebooks in that book.
Professor Pradella has
published extensively on labor,
migration, imperialism, and
alternatives to neoliberalism.
And she's one of the editors
of the Routledge handbook
of Marxism and post Marxism,
which should be out soon.
I'm gonna turn it right over to her
for a presentation entitled
Capital, A Book of Labor.
- Thank you, Paul, for this introduction.
And thanks for inviting me
I'm very happy to be here.
I try to present my topic,
which is I'm going to share
my screen with you now
in a slightly more original way,
or maybe to adapt to the new Zoom era.
So what I'm trying to do today is
to basically discuss
different interpretations
of Marx's "Capital"
and try to analyze with you
the role of labor within capital.
And I just wanted to start by asking you,
please, if you can,
I'm going now to post
something in this chat.
So if you can click on the link
that will appear on the chart
and if you can tell me what
Marx's Capital is about
from your point of view
and let me just send this.
So I just give you two minutes,
if you could just type the first two words
that come to your mind when
we mention Marx's Capital
and then these should appear in a window.
Yeah, please don't type them in the chat.
Try to click the link
that I've just sent you.
- The responses, oh, look at that.
- Okay, so this is
basically the word cloud
with the words that you're
still, I think, typing in.
But I think we can see that among
the most popular words are probably value,
exploitation, labor, capitalism,
surplus value, accumulation,
critique, exchange,
domination, time, economy, alienation.
Well, I think this is quite interesting.
It's a quite interesting cloud of words.
And let me just go back
to my presentation,
Yes I think that several
authors have tried to discuss
what the content of Marx's Capital
or the object of analysis
of Marx's Capital is.
For many scholars, and I
think this is also reflected
somehow in the word cloud
that we produced together.
These is some attention
to labor and so on,
but the main idea is really
that Capital is a book
about capitalism, about exploitation,
about value and so on.
And a group of scholars like Nancy Fraser
or Titia Bhattacharya have
criticized Max's Capital
and argue that capital
would be mainly concerned
with the obstruct labor
or labor power in the form
in which is useful to capital.
And for desserts daughters,
Marx left social reproduction
out of the picture.
And this not a focus on exploitation
would basically close off the analysis
of spaces of resistance,
which is my colleague argument.
And for Nancy Fraser
echoed by Debbie Harvey,
we would need to expand the understanding
of anticapitalist struggles beyond
the traditional Marxist Canon
and so look not just to struggles
between labor and capital
at the point of production,
but also at boundary struggles
of agenda domination,
ecology, imperialism, and democracy.
And my argument today is that
Capital is not really a book
about capital, but it's
a book against capital.
And in the last instance,
it's a book that analyzes the antagonism
between two social systems,
so between capitalism and communism.
And not seeing these from
my point of view results
from the same refined processes,
that Marx sees a place in
the commodity fetishism.
So in order to somehow de-fetishize
the reading of Capital,
I will look first start
by discussing Marx's concepts
of labor and exploitation
and I will argue that
these concepts are crucial
to these inter-capital's
emancipatory potential
and read it from the point
of view of the community
of three producers that Marx introduces
at the end of this section
on commodity fetishism.
I will then explain why
from my point of view,
the point on capital reproduction
is key to understanding
the global scope of Marx's analysis,
including imperialism
and social reproduction.
And then we'll conclude by
discussing what this does as
about Marx's conception
of the class struggle
and social revolution, both
in the 19th century and today.
And before I start, I
need to make a promise
because many people believe that Marx
was analyzing 19th century
England in Capital Volume One
but there, Marx also says
that he is using England
as a model to analyze the
overall fantasies of capitalism
and I think this is an important point
that we need to bear in mind,
which helps also explain why
the more capitalism develops,
the more relevant Marx's
analysis seems to be.
It's because he's looking
at overall time disease
and not just a specific historical model.
Okay, so it's clear
that Marx devoted quite
a lot of attention in capital
to labor exploitation,
but one could ask whether this focus
on labor exploitation really closes off
spaces of resistance.
And I think it's important
to bear in mind that
for Marx, labor is an organic metabolism
between humankind and nature
and from his point of view, contrary
to the classical economist was derived
from both labor and nature
not from labor alone.
And by selling their labor
power workers transfer
onto capital, their whole living power.
So they put these organic metabolism,
between humankind and nature
in the hands of capital
and by doing so, really these
create a complete overthrowing
of the relationship between
humankind and nature
and this is why for Marx in proportion,
as capital accumulates,
the situation of the worker
be his payment high or
low must grow worse, yeah.
So it's both a qualitative
and quantitative process
of impoverishment.
So even assuming that workers
are paid what's necessary
to cover their subsistence
and reproduction costs,
the value of the wage for
max is always lower than
the value that work is for
use in the production process.
And from the moment they
entered the hidden aboard
of production, capitalist
consume that level of power
with the exclusive goal of
expanding the surplus labor time
and increasing the
extraction of surplus value.
And that's why the development
of the productive forces
aims at creating a uniform
and continuous time
of valorization that renders
labor and purely abstract
and mechanical activity.
So in volume one from my point of view,
and I suggested reading the
chapters from corporation
to a large scale industry.
So those chapters are just
describing historical stages
in the development of capitalism,
but are also highlighting the
fundamental contradictions
of such development.
And Marx shows that
capitalism renders work
as source of mortification
rather than a human fulfillment
and that eating polishes
the workers turns them
into a fragment of themselves
and separates manual
and intellectual tasks and slaving science
on their capitals.
So it's really an analysis of
the progressive subordination
of labor or substantiation
of labor under capital.
And this process proceeds hand in hand
with the exploitation and
squandering of nature.
And this is why from my point of view,
Marxist theory of exploitation concerns,
the totality of capitalists such relations
and has an important ecological dimension
that resonates today, for example
in the studies of scholars
like Rob Wallace or John Bellamy, foster,
and other scholars who have shown that
the spread of pandemics like COVID-19,
are linked to industrial
agriculture and deforestation.
And so from this point of view, COVID-19
would therefore point to
the limits of capitalism
as an ecological and
ecological system as well.
Okay, let me see.
So, from Marx, one of
the fundamental goals
of the development of productive forces
is to repress a workers
resistance that grows along
with the cooperation of workers.
And to Marx, is not again,
just a historical face,
but it's the fundamental form
of the capitalist mode of production.
And it's the condition for the development
of the productive forces.
So in his point of view,
cooperation takes place
when numerous workers
work together side by side
in accordance with the plan,
whether in the same
process or in different,
but connected processes.
So I want to show you this light,
that basically visualizes
somehow part of the supply chain
of an iphone today, yeah?
So you can see here that Apple designs
the iPhone in California,
and then it supplies parts
that are produced all over the world
and are then assembled in
China, in Shenzen by Foxconn.
So now I have another quiz
for you, another question,
and I'm curious to see
what you think about this
let me just find it.
So what I would like to hear from you
in this kind of a silent way
is whether you think that workers along
the Apple supply chain cooperate or not?
So this is the link it's just a yes or no.
Okay, there is a kind of
people I've read split here,
so please vote, use your voice
don't miss this opportunity.
I will know whose this was well,
so do you see the results?
Okay, I'll go into, do you see
this slide with the results?
Yes, okay, so according to a majority,
but quite slim majority
only, just 35 of you,
they do cooperate while
27, they don't cooperate.
And for nine, what nine people
don't know really about it
or that they are not sure about it.
All right, so I will tell
you my interpretation
and then we can discuss
whether you agree or not.
Let me just resume.
Okay, so actually in capital,
Marx tells us that workers,
if we go back to the
previous slides here, sorry.
So he says that workers
cooperate when they work together
in accordance with the plan,
whether in the same
process or in different
but connected processes.
So from my point of view,
this means that works cooperate,
even if they don't work
in the same location
or in a single workplace
but even if they work in
different and connected locations.
So for example, in the case of Apple,
they're brought together
by capital control,
over deliver power, but not necessarily
by physical proximity.
And also in some passages
in the Marx argues
that the means of transport are part
of the direct production process, yeah.
So he seems to subsume space
on the accumulation process.
So from my point of view, but I'd be happy
to listen to what you think.
So this means that in this case, workers
are indeed cooperating even
if they are not working
in a single factory, but they
are spread all over the world.
And there is an important
point about cooperation
because for Marx by cooperating workers
become members of the collective worker
so he calls these biter
and he also said that
workers strip off the factors
of their individuality and develop
the capabilities of their species.
So for Marx cooperation is
really a very important aspect
of a capitalist the production relations
that is also potentially emancipatory
But the problem is that under capitalism,
these unprecedented development
of human capabilities
and power is capital
that is a force that
dominates and exploits both
the workers and the environment.
Okay, I just want to move now
and maybe this is also
linked to the question
of really what is capital
Marx looking at in capital?
Because, well, I think that in
order to discuss this point,
which is really about
the field of analysis
of capital volume one,
the seven on the process
of accumulation of capital
is quite important.
and this part shows that if we look
at the process of reproduction of capital,
the apparent autonomy
of capital disappears.
So if we look at the
production of the process,
capital doesn't exchange with the workers,
it kind of independent some of value,
but is actually exchanging the vary value
that workers create.
So capital appears to be entirely
the product of a wage labor,
not an independent social force.
So it's actually the
workers who create capital
as the force that oppresses
and exploits them.
And at the beginning of chapter 24 on
the conversion of surplus
value into capital,
Marx adds these very important
from my point of view,
footnote, like he argues,
well, here we take no account
of that's portrayed by means of which
a nation can change
articles of luxury, either
into means of production
or means of subsistence and vice versa.
In order to examine the
object of our investigation
in its integrity free
from all disturbing
subsidiary circumstances,
we must treat the whole
world as one nation
and assume that capital is production
is established everywhere
and has taken possession
of every branch of industry.
Okay, so I have another question for you.
So I found this passage
particularly puzzling really,
because, well I spent
a lot of time actually
trying to understand what does
it really mean here, right?
And so I'm just giving
you a a few options, okay.
So you can find these
options if you click here.
So I think what's probably been
the most dominant interpretation of this
is that Marx is analyzing
a national economy.
So he's obstructing from the world market
and looking at England in isolation
from the rest of the world.
Here you have a learning
Rosa Luxembourg that we'd have
a lot of people assuming
that that's the case.
Or he could be analyzing a
completely globalized system
where national and global levels coincide.
So he says, what does he say?
We must treat the whole
world as one nation.
Or he could just look at
the capitalistic economy
in the abstract.
And so at this level
of abstraction, really
the national and the global
levels don't really matter.
What do you think?
Okay, so I must say that my position,
my interpretation is a minority here,
but at least I'm very
happy because they have,
his interpretation is losing.
So only four people
believe that he's analyzing
a national economy which is an achievement
for me after many years of debates.
So, okay we just assume he's not analyzing
the national economy, which is good news,
but in majority believes
that he's actually looking
at a capitalistic economy in the abstract,
while the second most popular answer
is that he's looking at the
completely globalized system.
Okay, well, I think this is a plausible,
it's a plausible interpretation
that he's looking
at capitalistic economy in the abstract.
Also I think that the idea of treating
the whole world as one
nation somehow makes me think
of something different
so that the national
and the global level still
matters in Marx's analysis.
And also from my point of view,
basically posing this coincidence between
the national and the global
level actually allows you
to understand the process of expansion
from the national to the global level.
And from this point of
view, it's quite interesting
what the Marx argues in Capital volume one
in the same chapter,
because he argues that the
incorporation of new lands,
for example or the control
over a larger population,
or the application of science allow
for an expansion of carpenter's
field of a communication
independent of its actual
levels of development.
And so these seems to
say that actually capital
isn't bound to a given a
territory and the more it grows,
the more it becomes concentrated
and becomes concentrated in fewer hands.
The more its field of
accumulation expands.
Think for example,
of mergers and acquisitions
or the mobility of a finest
capital and contrary to widespread
belief that max believed
in the equalizing fantasies of the system.
The fact that the process of concentration
and centralization of capital
takes place at the
global level as actually
it polarizing fantasy because capital
tends to become centralized in the center
of the world economy
where higher value added
production activities
are also concentrated.
And Marx argues in volume three,
that investment in the colonies
or in today's low wage
countries is a major factor
that helps counteract
the tendency of the rate
of profit to fall and also
another way of counteracting
this tendency is to find new
sources of cheap raw materials.
And from my point of view,
this kind of analysis
helps explain both contemporary
processes of extractivism
and also the major shift of production
of industrial production
to the Global South
that has occurred in
the early bird period.
Well, this chart on the top
left hand side by John Smith
actually shows that
from the mid seventies,
the industrial workforce
in the Global South
has outnumbered that in the North.
And according to the word banks, 2019,
where development reports,
industrial jobs are further falling
in a high income countries,
which are the orange line
while they're further
increasing in East Asia.
Well, the total labor
force has been increasing
across the globe over
the last really 20 years.
So extractivism, and these
global shifts of production
to the Global cells,
I mean an increasing
reliance of Western capital
on the super expectation
of workers in the South,
which is something that
Marx basically discusses,
especially in his 1861-63
manuscript anticipating
from my point of view analysis
about the relationship
between dependency and superexploitation
by scholars like (inaudible)
Okay, so I think I need to move on
and I want to discuss another common view
that is that for Marx the
violence of primitive accumulation
or so-called primitive
accumulation would recedes
with the maturing of capitalism,
which is what the city of
Federici or David Harvey argue.
But these kinds of readings system size
the chapter on primitive accumulation
and miss it's systemic content.
And they also meet,
so I'm sure you already know this passage,
but the examples of primitive accumulation
in this very famous
passage from the chapter
on the Genesis of industrial capital,
for example, the optimum
Wars against China
didn't take place in
pre-industrial period,
but they actually took
place between the 1830s
and the 1860s, so this was
full industrial capitalism.
So from my point of view,
these are shows that for
Marx industrial capitalism
doesn't eliminate the matters
of so-called primitive accumulation,
but subsumed them under its logic.
In particular, in the industrial period,
the violence of economic
compassion is so powerful
that it takes a priority
over direct violence.
And this is really because
of the perverse tendencies
of the system, which
pushes more and more people
into the reserve army of labor.
And these kind of processes for Marx
were taking place both in England,
but also in the colonies
where in his view,
the profound barbarism of
Bushra civilization went naked.
So in colonial India, for example,
the combination of colonial domination
and industrial capitalism,
and what was previously the great workshop
of the cotton manufacturing of the world.
And that's Mike Davis showed in
lake Victorian holocausts
in the last last quarter
of the 19th century, the combination
of colonialism and
capitalism led to an increase
in rural poverty exacerbating families
and causing mass starvation
among the population.
And so these continuous constant
processes of dispossession
for my feed the global
reserve army of labor
and the traffic in human flesh
that from his point of view,
the capitalist world labor market, yeah.
So this kind of continuous
processes of dispossession
basically feed the global
reserve army of labor
and the global reserve army of
labor from his point of view
plays a fundamental role in introduction
because it affects labor in multiple ways.
And in particular, the
expansion of the reserve army
puts pressure on employed workers,
allowing capitalists to push down wages
and also to increase labor
exploitation in a vicious circle
of overwork and unemployment
that takes place really
not just at the national,
but also at a global level.
Okay, so just, we go back to the question
whether Marx really leaves
social reproduction out of the picture.
Well, from my point of view,
it's Marx himself in capital volume,
one who criticizes the classical economist
for leaving out such a reproduction.
And he describes Capital
as inanimated monster,
which begins to work as if it's body
were by loved possessed.
And he also uses biblical metaphors,
like talking about money
that differentiates itself
as a regional value from
itself, a surplus value
just as God, the father
differentiates himself
from himself as God the son,
or the both are of the same age and form,
in fact, one single person.
And I think that this kind
of language seems to be
an implicit critique
of the market approach
of the classical economists
who reduce economic relations
to market relations
between private individuals
and therefore assume their existence,
that take it for granted
and live social reproduction
out of the picture.
And this kind of approach
fully criticized by Marx
who starts from a completely
different point of view.
And he argues, as we discussed earlier,
by selling the liberal power workers
are actually transferring onto Capital
their entire productive power,
including their reproductive power.
And this kind of transfer
becomes even clear
if we look at the process
of capital reproduction
from a social point of view
and in its continuous flow,
because if we do this,
we see that throughout
the lives workers exchange
with capital their entire liberal power.
So the fact that capital
is buying it piece by piece
instead of a mass like with the slave,
it's actually a source of
precarity and dependence
on the part of the worker,
but the result is always a
condition of wage slavery,
according to Marx.
And so these shows that substantially
there isn't a substantial
difference with slavery itself
and the antagonism between
capital and wage labor
also includes this fear
of life making activities
and social needs.
And the gender dimension
is of this antagonism
between even clear from Marx
in the industrial period,
when really he says the
labor of women and children
was the first result of
the capitalist application
of machinery and Marx
shows how this developed
in complete antagonism with family labor
and the social needs of
the workers at the time.
Marx also shows that although
capitalism undermines
the economic foundations
of the patriarchal family,
it also relies on it to ensure
it's privatized reproduction,
and these can worsen
patriarchal domination
from some points of view,
but at the same time,
it also empowers women and children
and creates the conditions for overcoming
the patriarchal division of
labor as part of the process
of overthrowing capitalism itself.
So of course, this brings me
to the question I anticipated
of the class struggle according to Marx.
It is also quite well known
that Marx puts forward quite
an optimistic view at the
end of capital volume one,
when he argues that the
development of capitalism,
there is increasing class polarization
and so the world of
the working class grows
and these growing people
it's due to the fact
that accumulation is due
to increase in cooperation,
which is the basis of it.
And the cooperation favors a
working class consciousness
and organization and so
this process of cooperation
actually creates the conditions
for the expropriation
of the exropriators.
So I don't know how much time I have for.
- We don't have a formal
requirement really
nobody's cracking the whip over us or you,
but we wanna give people
enough time to ask questions.
So if you want to take a
little more time, that's great.
If you wanna stop and take some questions
and go back to something
that's also terrific.
- No, I think I need 10
minutes to conclude, yeah.
Maybe I will leave this
I had another question for
you, but I was just curious,
maybe we can discuss it later,
whether this idea of the expropriation
of the expropriators still make sense today
with billionaire was skyrocketing,
especially in the wake of the pandemic
and rich not paying taxes,
but maybe this is something
we will discuss later on.
So what I want to do now
is basically to engage
with this question, right,
because Marx seems really
optimistic to here,
he presents these like these,
the kind of natural necessity.
And also this is quite a problematic part
I think of volume one.
And the traditional
interpretation of this passage
is that for Marx, industrialization leads
to the concentration of a
production in big factories,
the concentration of workers
in industrial cities.
And so these really would translate
in the growing class
consciousness and making basically
such a revolution in inevitable.
But according to the kind
of dominant point of view,
this kind of interpretation
of view of the dynamic
of working class power
would be obsolete given
the shift of industrial
production towards East Asia
and declining power of the
working class in the West.
And so this would be one of the many,
Marx's predictions that proved
to be completely obsolete.
But from my point of view,
Marx's his argument is a
bit more complex than this,
and I'm just moving to the next slide.
Well, the first thing to say
about these is that for Marx,
the movement for the
reduction of the working day
is the premise for any
advancement of the working class.
And the demand for shorter hours is key
because it targets the
link between exploitation
and impoverishment that is at the center
of the process of capital
accumulation and creates
the conditions to build solidarity
between employed workers and
be unemployed native born,
and immigrant workers and
also between different genders
and the generations.
In particular working time
is key to link struggles
around production and social reproduction.
And these are demand that the
labor movement put forward
in different national
context and also became part
of an international struggle.
For Marx support for the most
suppressed workers is crucial
for the advancement of the working class.
And in particular, he makes
the example of English,
white male workers, who on
the one side behave like
a slave dealers selling
their children and wife,
but also max notes that
it was that struggle
that achieved the
shortening of working hours
for women and children,
which also ended up
benefiting male adult workers.
And the extension of factory
legislation put an end
to the most extreme forms of exploitation
in the domestic industry,
which were kind of 19th century
sweat shops that relate on
the patriarchal family brutally
to exploited women and children.
And so the extension of a
factory legislation enhance
the process of concentration of production
in big factories and industry centers,
which resulted from an
interplay of technological
and political factors.
So from this point of view,
the class struggle is
not a secondary factor
in the development of capitalism,
but actually shapes
capitalism development itself.
And for the same reason,
we could say that the
process of concentration
of industrial production in big factories
or industrial centers is not definitive
and Marx was actually quite aware of this
and in the 1867 address
that he wrote on behalf
of the international, the general council
to its Roseanne Congress,
he argues that in order
to oppose the workers,
the employers in England,
either bring in workers from abroad
or as transfer manufactured to countries
where there is a cheap labor force, yeah.
So it's not like he
wasn't aware of processes
of production restructuring,
but by presupposing
capital's field of action
to be fully globalized
from my point of view,
capital makes it possible to
understand what Beverly silver
called the dialectic between
what resistance to expectation
and capital efforts to
overcome that resistance
by constantly revolutionizing production
and social relations.
So these constant process
of spatial reorganization
that is a part of this dialectic
is however based on labor cooperation
and so it could not
slippers all over the world
and creates new sources of
structural power for workers.
So at the same time,
it's a weekends from some points of view,
but also empowers workers in new way.
And an example of this are the struggles
of immigrant workers in
the logistics sector,
both in the United States.
But I started in
particular Italy that even
if they're often very precarious
dependent on the document
and so in a kind of
immune immigrant status,
logistics workers have a huge potential
to disrupt supply chains
through strikes and blockades.
And so for any talent redoing your newest,
other Milani in a warehouse
where fresh food is stored,
a four hour blockade means between
200 and 300,000 years last year.
And these kinds of disruptive
potential helps explain
why over the last 10 years,
the movement of logistics
workers in Italy has been
able to achieve substantial improvements
in both wages and working conditions,
even though the labor
conditions are more generally
in the country have worsened
quite substantially.
And I think that this kind of
contradiction re-emerge is now
in the wake of a global 19,
because on the one side,
the pandemic is leading
to a massive job crisis
with the mass unemployment increasing
the competitive pressures on workers.
And so in this way, the
pandemic is revealing
the ecological and economic
dimensions of Marx's law
of impoverishment of the working class.
But on the other side, the
pandemic has also revealed
the essential importance of
jobs that are undervalued
or not valued at all like for example,
agricultural work often performed
by undocumented immigrant
workers or care work
by women in the family.
So I have a question here,
if you want to answer.
So whether from your point of view,
the pandemic is only weakening labor,
or is also creating new
sources of workers' power.
Let me look at the chart here
Right, Okay, so, yeah.
So in majority believes that
it's actually doing both, yeah.
So 37 against six per week in labor
and five increasing workers disruptive.
Okay, which is interesting, okay.
So I think, I mean my
presentation today really wanted
to highlight the global
scope of Max's understanding
of the class struggle.
And I think that this is really
always characterized Marx's
conception of the class struggle,
but over time made Marx
became increasingly aware
of the challenges to
international solidarities
in the context of imperialist
racialized violence.
And it is that for no
coincidence or no accident
from my point of view,
that volume one doesn't add
with the expectation of the expropriators
but with the chapter on
the theory of colonization.
So I liked it when a poet was reading some
of the passages about the
importance of anti-colonial
struggles in Marx already
in the early fifties,
when Marx supported
uprisings in China and India
against British colonialism,
and actually believed that they
could either react on Europe
and accelerate the tendency
towards crisis and revolution,
or they could be the premise for
the capitalist national
development of these countries.
And Marx also followed
enthusiastically the development of
the civil war in the United States.
And as black abolitionists
like Frederick Douglas,
he believed that the outcome of the war
depended on the mobilization
of African Americans
and therefore it depended on
the emancipation of the slaves.
And this emancipation in
his view was the premise
for any further progress
of the liberal movement
because as it's well known
from his point of view,
laboring white skin
cannot emancipate itself
when it is branded in a black skin.
And indeed the movement
for the eight hour day
immediately grew in the U.S. after the end
of the civil war and
then spread to Europe.
So when Marx discusses the movement
for the reduction of the
working day, he's not,
it doesn't tell me mine
that pure class struggle
that between bourgeoisie and proletariat
that proceeds in linear ways
in separate national context
but he has in mind is
international movement
against both exploitation and oppression.
At the end of the sixties,
Marx changed his mind on the relationship
between proletariat and
anti-colonial struggles.
And so while initially in the manifesto,
he proclaimed that social revolution
was key to the liberation of
the colonies 10 years after,
he was discussing with Angus, the dangers
that Britain's exploitation of the word
would create a bushwalk
proletariats silent or complicit
with these domination.
And at the end of the sixties,
he concluded that independence
of Island was the premise
for the emancipation of the
working class in England.
So it was really in the
colonies that that was
the key to the class
struggle even in the centers
of the system and support
working class support
for the independence of
Ireland was also the condition
for causing the anti Irish
racism that was sparked
by the ruling classes in England.
And, that's an interesting,
because it's in the same
period that Marx also realizes
that such a revolution is
impossible without women
and so he's actually paying
more and more attention
to the role of women within the revolution
and helps draft the problem
of the workers' part
in France in 1880, that
actually includes demands
for such a responsibility
for the care of older people
and disabled people and so for a kind
of sharing of the tasks
of social reproduction.
And I just believe that
Mike's is a reflection
and study of Island where
also kind of, he was actually
it was in the light of the
experience in the United States
and the outcomes of the American civil war
that Marx decides to take a
more explicit stand on Ireland.
And the comes with clear
and clear understanding
that resisting expectation
requires suppose
in different forms of violence
and racist oppression.
And so I just wanted to
conclude with the address
that the international
center to the people
of the United States and
address that was written
with the input of a Marx
himself that advocated
a policy of radical reconstruction,
including full citizenship
rights for black Americans.
And Dubai's actually
underlined that what he's
called a bond address
contained also a warning
so that if people don't of the U.S.
didn't immediately declare
blacks free and equal
without any reserve there
would sooner or later face
a new struggle which will once more drench
the country in blood, yeah.
So there is this kind
of increasing awareness
that it's impossible to oppose expectation
without resisting imperialism and racism,
which I think is still
very important today
when we think about the
relevance of Marx, thank you.
- This is the moment where
everyone would applaud,
and I know scholars don't
live for the applause,
but it really feels good.
So I want to thank you imagine a room of
a hundred people applauding for
a tremendously hopeful presentation.
I want to give my colleague
and collaborator Paul writer,
a chance to engage you to ask a question.
And I have a question for you too
and perhaps we can ask the
students from the seminar
to put their questions into
the chat at this moment,
either privately to me or to everyone
and then we will go to those
questions and unmute you.
Paul, do you want that?
- Sure, first of all, thank you so much
for that presentation.
I'm rethinking a lot of
passages from Capital
as I asked this question,
which is maybe not the best thing to do,
but it really is literally
very thought provoking
what you said.
And certainly for me, this attempt
to work Marx's various statements about
the world outside Europe into
a a kind of coherent framework
is very exciting and
I am grateful for this
really stimulating and well
thought out presentation,
but I'm gonna ask a question
that maybe in view of this
in view of the breadth of your discussion
seems a little small hearted.
So forgive me for that
if if it seems that way,
I was intrigued by your way
of framing your distance
to various highly influential
interpretations of Marx
by talking about how his idea
of the fetish as you see it,
or his idea of labor, as you see at
the exploitation of labor
has itself been fetishized.
The language is very suggestive there
and I was wondering if you
could just walk me through that
a little bit, since it
was stated initially,
and then you were
proceeded to your reading.
- Yes.
Shall we collect, thank you.
- Maybe I'll ask you a question too.
- Okay, yeah.
- That's good, You wanna do two at once?
Why not?
Okay, terrific.
Well, it really opened up
a whole new horizon for me.
I do think thinking of the
field of analysis as global
and the field of struggle is global
it fits my understanding of Marx.
A lot of that doesn't make
it into volume one of capital
explicitly, but it's
all over his journalism,
his letters, his involvements
so that, that really makes perfect sense.
But in terms of
revolutionary possibilities,
and I'm really glad you brought that up.
I take your question to be something like
do the redistribution of
relations of production,
but also the exploitation.
So exploitation has moved around,
it's not just within the factory,
but in all different places,
under all different conditions.
It's kind of, there's a
division of exploitation,
I would say today, that's
different than in Marx this time
or different than he recognized.
Your question is something like,
does this redistribution
change the analysis of capital,
maybe even the categories?
And does it also then
change the anticapitalist
possibilities and your
position is that Marx
was already there in a lot of ways,
and we should turn to those
and exploit them in order
to help fight the struggle.
Here's here's a problem I see.
He was thinking of a collective action
and the cooperation chapter
really makes this clear over
and over and over again.
He was thinking the
unity of space and time
for cooperation on the
labor floor is really
because the power that the collective gets
is because they are facing
one particular capitalist
who then needs them as a collective
because it's more efficient.
If the people who pull the
iron ore out of the earth,
obstruct the making the
steelworks, that's one thing,
but it doesn't count as cooperation
or as collective action
say the means of production
is not included in that for Marx.
So my question is something like,
does the image of a chain bring with it
different possibilities of
different kinds of struggle?
And if so, how fair is that?
If the collective
strikes everyone sits out
and what happens happens,
but if the logistic workers,
the immigrant logistics workers,
if we're depending on
them alone to disrupt
the supply chain it seems highly unfair,
very dangerous for them and
different than a revolution.
So maybe you could respond to that mess
that I just threw in your hands.
- Okay, I think I should
that I to respond,
thank you to the two poles.
Okay, so then thank you for
for your stimulating questions.
So the first question is
really about my critique
of certain interpretations
of Max's capital.
So the idea that like factor,
so the criticism, for example,
that he's just looking at
labor power or exploitation,
and this would close off both the analysis
of such a reproduction and
the analysis of resistance.
And I think this is a kind of
reductionist interpretation
of the antagonism between
capital and wage labor.
And I include here also, I
really admire, like for example,
Maria MIS or cloudy
from Valoff and others,
feminist scholars, who also say,
well, this antagonism between
wage labor and Capital
doesn't include is not adjacent antagonism
so we can't understand
the question of gender
in the light of, of Marx's analysis.
And they think that this
underestimates first,
what this kind of exchange of labor power
for a wage is about.
So that one workers are
exchanging their living power.
So their power a species being,
I adjust left like a passage
from my senior economic
and philosophical manuscripts
when he argues that labor is life activity
is the productive life itself
is the life of this pieces
is life in January in life.
So it's really so by
selling the liberal power,
it's this power, this
living power of the species
that is appropriated by capital.
And that's why the complete
relationship between
humankind and nature is overthrown
so it's subordinated under
the needs of accumulation
and this also includes the
reproduction of the species.
Another point is that for
example, scholars, like,
I don't know how long I should go,
but scholars like Lisa for example,
believe that Marx isn't
looking at the global system in
capital volume one but national economy.
So since you have migration
and other forms of social
reproductionn cannot
be included in volume one, but of course,
if we agree that he's looking
really at the national economy
or at the global economy or
a globalized system or so on,
then I think the dimension of
this antagonism is different.
And then the second point I think,
is that I want to highlight
in answering this question is
the question of cooperation,
which I think is a very
underestimated aspect
of Marx's analysis.
So I think that even the
idea that by focusing
on the exploitation, Marx
would close off spaces
of resistance underestimates the fact
that for max value production
is based on cooperation
and cooperation empowers the workers.
So if we don't understand this,
I think we are closing out
of the spaces of resistance
in our interpretations of capital.
- Thanks, if I might jump in for a second,
I suppose, what interested
me about your likening
of these misreading or you're framing them
as a kind of like fetishizing
of the the fetish idea
to an extent is that it
raises the question of
what it is about Marx's
presentation, language framing
and so on that encourages
misreadings or is that so
in other words for him that's
certainly true of capitalism
the way it works is such
that people misunderstand it,
take some things for others.
Sometimes it appears
to have fantastic forms
because it in fact appears
to have fantastic forms,
but this also throws people off.
And so that's when I
perhaps should have said
that a little more clearly and
asked the question initially,
but what is your sense of that?
Is there something about
obviously people come to Marx
with agendas and it's all very freighted,
but is in the argument
is of course difficult,
which you could say is something that,
leads itself to misunderstanding,
but they find that there's something about
the framing of the language.
And so on that, that lends
itself to the misread things,
the passage, one of the
passages that you had us discuss
or think about and respond
to, for example, you said,
you've thought about it for a long time
and you see how it could
be read in either ways,
do you, in multiple ways,
do you think that that's fairly typical
and that's to an extent
the source of this?
- Well, the first thing
to say is that Marx
is focusing capital
volume one is not about
social reproduction so I think clearly
he's focusing on the production process
and so these could give the
impression that he's looking
at this, rather than at the
kind of trying to analyze it,
totality of capitalist social relations.
And I think that there has been a tendency
also in interpretations
of capital volume one
to see it as restricted to the
level of the factory, yeah.
Or the national economy.
And so these kinds of
interpretation may have influenced
a certain idea of its object of analysis.
I also think, well, we can
find max his attention to
these in his notebooks for example,
especially while already
in the early fifties
he's looking at issues of the relationship
between the family and the
different modes of production.
And then he's going back
to these in the late period
of his life, with his what
so-called ethnological notebooks
that were used by Angus
when he added to the origin
of the family, private
property and the state.
So, well, I would say
it's a question of focus
it's a question of probably of
the language due to the fact
that that's not the
main object of analysis.
And also maybe one,
thing that it is through
that as I said,
it's really in the late
sixties and early seventies
in the work of the strikes in
France and the Paris commune
and so on that he starts to
stress this issue of the kind
of centrality of women in the struggle.
Well, I think there is a
language in capital that somehow
reflects sort of nostalgia
for the kind of manufacturing,
male worker and some form of kind
of traditional family relations.
So there is also these aspect
that I think is a factor
that changes later on.
I don't think I satisfied you, but--
- I'm just thinking I don't
mean to look skeptical.
Thank you so much.
And I'll let you move
on to Paul's question.
- Well pole question, I think North,
so I think it's a very important question
because okay there are two things
that I want to highlight here.
One is the question whether the
kinds of global distribution
of workers today and the kind
of restructuring of production
really changes Marx's the analysis
and also about the
revolutionary possibilities.
When on the one side, I would
say it doesn't change it.
It's actually, I see, as I think that
he's not looking at 19th century England,
but I believe he's posing this
a completely globalized
system yeah where capitalist
production has established
itself everywhere.
So I think that what we are
witnessing today is actually
an approximation to these limits
that is opposing in capital
and so for example, the
fact that production
has industrial production
has relocated to the South
and the West in Europe
and the U.S. and Japan
have lost their industrial monopoly
has actually globalized
industrial competition
and so this is a manifesting
the impoverishing tendencies
of the system in a much clearer way.
So this is actually
allowing the development
of these tendencies to unfold.
But I agree with you that I
think that's actually the key.
So, and I think that he's
an ambiguity in Marx himself
about this concept of cooperation,
because on the one side there is this idea
that there is some form of
unity of space and time.
And so cooperation would
emerge from this, right?
And so these hubs explain the
kind of very optimistic tone
of the end of the part
of the expropriators.
So the idea that actually,
so there is this kind of cooperation
that grounds working class
organization consciousness
and so on.
On the other side, I think
that there is still this form
of space and time unity
even if we look at this
entire supply chain, right?
Not just because of the
disruption of logistics,
but for example,
Barbra silver shows that especially
given just in time production,
even if we stop a part
of this supply chain,
this can have a disruptive potential
all over the chain, right?
- Can I ask a question about
that just while you're on it,
just thinking of Marx's
presentation of cooperation
in volume one,
it really is that the
collective faces off against
one capitalist who owns
their means of production.
So what's to keep Apple from say,
there's resistance at some
point in the supply chain,
just shifting the supplier,
that's what can't happen
let's say in this workspace
where the capitalist
absolutely needs everyone
to be working together in
order to get their return
and they can't do it otherwise.
So if the cooperation breaks down there,
it's tantamount to them
losing their business or not,
becoming impossible for them
to continue as a capitalist,
whereas applicant simply
change their suppliers.
- But I mean, isn't it the same thing
that Marx was describing in the address
to the Lausanne Congress, so that in order
to face workers' struggles,
English capitalist
while moving production to
countries where wages were lower.
So it's the same, sorry,
I didn't hear you.
- I just think it's a
very specific argument
about cooperation that leads to an idea
of collective action and the
idea of revolution as a kind
of overthrow of one capitalist
or of the whole system.
And well, if the relocated
manufacturer let's say
is still directly responsible
for the capitalists profit,
that's fine, then it works.
But in so far as they can
simply switch suppliers.
So that's where Mark's
makes the difference
between means of
production and production.
I don't mean to get very technical
I only think it's worth
sticking with Marx's framework
and developing other vocabulary
and other revolutionary
possibilities that you brought up,
but disruption is very
different than overthrow
is very different than crisis.
It's not actually a term I think that Marx
uses disruption blockade.
I don't know if that makes sense.
- Well, I think that the
power for disruption, I mean,
it's not a term that he uses,
but we can explain the
power for disruption
through cooperation
because it's the fact that
the division of labor is
so developed means that
it requires increasing cooperation yeah
in order to produce a product
and these creates
possibilities for disruption.
So I think it's that actually proportional
to the process of cooperation.
- Okay, I think that's a great answer.
Maybe it's a good time to
turn to a couple of questions
from students in the seminar,
and then we can open up
the floor to other people.
I know there's a lot of
comments and questions.
I want to turn to Bilal,
Who's a student in the seminar.
Audrey, if you're hearing me,
would you open up his mic?
- Can you repeat their names please?
- Yeah, Ii's Bilal Moin M-O-I-N.
- [Bilal] Question about what corporation.
So when Mark describes the
subjugation of colonies,
he often brings up the device
risk schisms of society,
that the capitalist creates
a particular advantage of
the oppressor, the masses.
And this has made quite
evident when he talks
about the Indians 1857.
He specifically references the
British divide at improper.
So given that describes
the unity of monsters
on the value of the nature of masses
to overcome corporation
or does it see corporation
as only a tool to oppress the workers,
or could it also be an agency
of freedom specifically
in this context?
- Thank you.
- Then we go onto some more questions
you wanna collect them?
Okay, great.
Why don't we go to Nancy?
So there's only one student
who proposed a question.
So anyone else from the seminar
who wants to pop a question
in the chat, we can come back to you,
but we can go now to Nancy KO.
Hi, thank you so Much.
I'm Nancy, I'm a PhD student
at Columbia, actually.
So I'm curious as to whether
you can talk about your interpretation
as it might relate to Moshe histones
in time labor and social capital.
The reason I bring up the
stones interpretation of Marx
is that I think one thing
that's sort of bothering me
in the way that we're
talking about labor here
is that we're only talking
about it and it's sort
of concrete aspects.
So we're talking about, for
example, Apple's laborers,
but for Princestone,
importantly in capital
labor is both concrete, a
thing that produces use values,
but also socially general and
abstract and produces value as
the form of wealth and capitalism.
So I wonder if this
might partially account
for the difficulty of revolution
interpreting that as we may
precisely that labor, and
only it's concrete form
or interpreted only in this concrete form,
escapes this other aspect of labor.
And then with regard
to kind of this sort of
one of your last slides about what to do
with Marx's capital today,
I think Princestone
would say that, I mean,
he recently passed away,
but I think he would say that Marx
is more relevant now than ever, not just
because capital, as you said, wasn't just
a historical account, but a
sort of theory of a system.
But I wonder if you could
speak specifically to his idea
of sort of the kind of
treadmill effect, right?
So the ways in which due
to the kind of temporally
determined nature of value
value becomes, distributed
evermore thinly across
kind of ever-growing
some of commodities and so on that account
of the treadmill effect,
proletarian labor becomes
increasingly anachronistic, right?
And so in contrast material wealth, right?
Like the super billionaires
like Jeff Bezos,
their material wealth becomes
ever easy to accommodate,
accumulate rather at the
same time that the value
of proletarian labor becomes
increasingly irrelevant
to their resistance.
So I wonder because we're bringing up
this whole troubling thing of the fact
that the very people that we
think Marx's holds responsible
for the possibility of revolution are also
the most vulnerable.
I don't think that he's
holding them responsible
for that revolution.
I don't think that he sees or
he saw the proletariat class
as the standpoint of the critique.
I think Princestone says
capital is a critique
of labor in capitalism,
not a critique of capital
from the standpoint of labor.
- Do you wanna go from here or
do you want to take one more?
- I will take one more.
Yes, thank you, thank you, Nancy.
- I want to invite Berta
Morata to ask their question.
Berta would you like to go ahead?
I can also read out the
question for you if you prefer.
They might be there on muted.
I can see that, but they
might be having trouble
with mikes or whatever.
Why don't I read the question?
It came a little while ago.
It says, how can the reading
of capital help challenge
the productive forces, for example,
in extraction of iron or in Kiruna
where workers are highly
paid and extraction outputs
or appropriation ever increasing.
It's the biggest iron
ore mine in the world.
I guess they wanna know
how capital can be useful
in challenging that, where
it's getting bigger and bigger
and I guess the exploitation
is not as obvious.
Professor Pradella I leave this to you now.
- Okay, thank you.
Thank you everyone for this questions.
Yes Bilal I'm not sure
that I fully understood,
but I definitely agree that there
is this important emancipatory dimension
of Marxism analysis of cooperation.
And yes so this also applies
of course to the colonies.
Regarding the question
about laboring capital
and Bosstones interpretation.
While I think that the
interpretation I put forward
is actually quite the
opposite to Bosstones.
First with regard to con
concrete and obstruct labor,
I think that, I mean,
from my point of view,
I'm not an expert on bosstone
but it seems to fetishize Capital
and basically overlook the dialectic
between concrete and abstract labor.
And what I wanted to say
in particular was that
the reduction of concrete
labor to abstract labor
is a violent process that takes place
in the production process, right.
That helps explain also
workers revolts, yeah
and opposition to the development
of the productive forces.
And the idea that Marx
that capital is a book
in which basically capital is a subject
from my point of view,
completely overlooks
the fact that in section
in the part and capital reproduction,
Marx says that if we
look at the reproduction
of the relationship
capital is just objectified
third labor, right?
So from the point of view of the totality,
it's the working class
that reproduces itself
as dependent on capital.
And so the power to change
things today is still the power
of the working class from my point of view
and this is because they
control the production process.
and this has become even more clear today
in the wake of the pandemic,
how important workers are,
or for example there is a McKinsey report
that shows that because
of natural disasters,
climate change and stuff like that,
corporations are going to stop in months.
They have a disruption of
one month, every seven years,
and this will cost them
a huge amount of money.
I don't remember how much money,
but I couldn't believe it.
So the idea that both the workers
and of course the natural
disasters caused by capitalism
can produce such a disruption,
I think helps explain.
So because of their structural power,
why the workers do they
still have this power?
And they are showing this,
maybe it's more difficult for
us in Europe or in the West,
but Chinese workers,
Indian workers, and so on,
have been engaged in waves of labor unrest
over the last decades.
And this has led to concrete improvements
in their conditions
so it's not like the class
toggle has disappeared.
I think this is also maybe
a bit of a eurocentric point
of view that leads to this conclusion.
And yeah, so regarding extractivism and
how can we understand the exploitation
or how can Marx criticize,
the productive forces
if there is extractivism
maybe natural degradation
but at the same time,
wages are relatively high.
I think that in order to
understand this point,
we need to look at a
Marxist theory of the wage
that has actually different dimension
so Marx differentiate the nominal wage,
the real wage and the relative wage, yeah.
So you can even have very
high wages relatively
for example, let's say Henry Ford,
when he inaugurated the
assembly line, he said,
well, he had the problem because workers
didn't want to work there anymore
because labor conditions
were so awful, right?
And so he said, well,
the only way to keep workers
here is to raise the wage
to the $5 a day.
And he says, well, this has basically been
the best measure to cut labor costs
that I have ever taken, right?
So by increasing wages,
he has cut labor costs,
reduced labor costs, why?
Because of increased productivity.
So in that relative terms,
the relative wage of the workers still,
they could earn $5 a day
they could buy their Ford car
maybe after, I don't know,
one or two years, but in relative terms,
in comparison to Ford's profits,
they had actually become poor, right.
And I think that these can
apply to different contexts,
like the one that the examples you made.
But also if we look at, for example,
a Chinese workers today,
because of their struggles,
they have achieved many of them,
industrial workers have
achieved improvements
in their real wages but still inequality
is skyrocketing in China
because of this difference
between the relative wage
and the real wage, which is basically
workers purchasing power.
- If I could respond to one of your points
So, I mean, I take the point
about sort of Princestone
and kind of fetishizing or
perhaps we fetishizing capital
in capital and his
interpretation of capital.
But I don't know there's something
that seems to me a
little bit too optimistic
about your account, because
let's take the environment
and global warming and climate change,
which I appreciate how
central it's sort of
it was in your presentation.
I think that it's not enough to think that
the deleterious effects of climate change
can be sort of overrun by efforts
of working class alone, right?
The reality is that there
are large corporations
that are responsible for the vast majority
of carbon emissions in the
sorry be in the world today
and I think precisely what
postpone is trying to point out
that Marx is trying to point out fine,
take away the part about
capital being the subject
of his critique.
What he's trying to point out is that
there's an increasing disconnects
between the working class as
the enabling sort of factor
of capital production, as
you point out on the one hand
and then, value on the other hand, right?
Like so I wonder if from the
perspective of a corporation,
having to lose income for one month,
every seven years just becomes a new norm
it doesn't become a sort of
disabling sort of factor.
I think that precisely what
DPS Chakrabarti and Amitabh
gauche have pointed out with
regard to climate change
is that it forces us to
content with problems
for which the will of the working
class alone is not enough.
Maybe I'm being too pessimistic though.
- Yes, but I don't understand
if you expect a basis
or whoever to change the
mind and suddenly, you say,
well, we want a different system.
I mean, that's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying that it's
just the working class
I think the working class is the center
of such a transformation.
I think what I'm trying to say,
even with the examples of anti racism
and the kind of different
kind of struggles
is that I believe or the question
about production and reproduction.
it's just like having
a focus on production
doesn't exclude all the other spheres
of social reproduction of a society.
So the point is we need
to unite the struggles
around production and reproduction
around racism, imperialism, and so on.
And I think that the real
change or social change
can take place when they
also expand to production.
when there is a kind of
alliance or a connection between
these struggles that also
involves the workers.
I mean this is what happens
happened in the seventies.
In, many countries, it was the connection
between students,
workers, women, and so on
that were able to actually
achieve some improvements.
I just believe we forget this
and we have a value
deductions interpretation
of our labor struggles.
So on the contrary, the ideas like that,
even anti iImperial history
resistance is a force
that is not external
to the class struggles.
So it's a much broader
and dynamic consumption
of the class struggle
from my point of view,
that includes peasants and
dispossessed people and so on.
but I don't think that the
corporation will change the mind
or attitude, so I wouldn't
expect much from them.
- So we take a couple more questions.
Okay, I'm going to forgive me
if I've missed your question
somewhere in the queue.
If I did, you can repost
it towards the bottom
and I'll get to it.
I'm gonna read for Felix Spook vault
is makers networking.
This question, would you agree that Marx's
own analysis appears to show why
a completely globalized capitalist system
is an impossibility.
His analysis of the
centralization of capital
could be an example.
As you noted this process
necessarily marginalizes
particular world regions,
but might this imply
for your interpretation
of the passage from chapter 24 on treating
the world as one nation,
perhaps there's a fourth
possible interpretation.
you can read this yourself
in the, in the chat
- Sorry can you--
- it's a little bit, I
don't know 10 entries up
from the bottom in the
chat now that's just to me,
I'll repost it to the whole group.
- Yeah thank you.
And then while we're
mulling that one over,
can we go to Baruc Jimenez Contrera?
Who has a question Can we unmute Baruc.
Did you find him?
Baruc Jimenez Contrera.
- Is that mike working?
- I don't know Baruc are you here?
- [Baruc] Are you listening?
- Yes.
- [Baruc] I want to ask you
what do you think about
the change in the viewpoint
of the market United
State economic trends?
Like the investigation of(inaudible)
and no has a more humanistic
perspective (inaudible)
- Thank you for that.
Great, for the moment.
That's all our questions.
- Okay, thank you.
Can I ask the person who
posted this question about
the centralization of capital,
maybe to explain what they mean that
the centralization of
capital is an example
of why a completely globalized
system is impossible?
- That's for Felix Spook vault.
Maybe give some more
explanation where you see this
in Marx's analysis,
that a completely globalized
system is an impossibility.
And maybe while he does that,
you want to go on to
Baruc's question could be.
- Okay.
Well, that's an interesting question
I had never really, so
it's about the develop
this development of Marxist
in the United States,
but I know the work by Sweezey and so on
and I actually think that
Bellamy foster has quite a kind
of, it's an interesting
global approach in the sense
that is analyzing different
aspects of Marx's analysis
from the reserve army
to the metabolic rift
now, for example, COVID-19.
So I hadn't thought
about it in these terms,
but it's surely something
interesting to think about.
- Okay.
I don't see Felix
expanding on his question
or completely globalized
as opposed to tangentially
globalizing or tending to globalize.
I see the distinction he's
making is between your reading
of Marx as capturing this tendency
and then the idea of a
completely globalized system.
- Yeah, so on the one side,
I agree in the sense that,
for example, seen even the idea
of the centralization of
capital Marx talks about
this process of centralization
that tends towards basically
the concentration of
the property of capital
in the hands of a single
capital within a given society.
Yeah, so he talks in these,
in these terms when he talks about
the process of centralization.
So he sees this tendency
towards centralization,
but at the same time, of course,
this is always a competitive process
because capital only exists in competition
with other capitals.
So I don't put forward here,
the idea of for example,
of Uttar imperialism, yeah.
That would lead to a single
process of centralization.
So what I'm arguing here is
that because there is always
the link to the national
economy and this state.
These 10 tendency towards
centralization at the global level
actually enhances the competitive pressure
between different capital link
to specific nation States, yeah.
And so I see these as
an expression of the,
kind of the kind of tensions
and tendency towards interim
period is conflict
express exactly by these,
on the one side,
the tendency towards the
kind of the global level.
And on the other side,
the continuing presence of competition,
which is inherent in the
process of accumulation.
But with regard to the idea that
the process might necessarily marginalize
particular word regions, that's what
I'm not completely sure
about or I agree with,
because I don't understand what
you mean by marginalization,
because I understand these marginalization
as an expression of the
integration of these regions
in the capitalist world markets,
not as an expression of
their exclusion from it.
Yeah, so for example,
underdevelopment is a result
of the development it's part and parcel
of capitalist development
on a global scale,
rather than a result of
a lack of development.
So these are why I
wanted to hear from you,
but for sure there is a
fourth possible interpretation
and well, maybe we could we
will discuss it in future.
- Can I ask you on that line,
just for your bigger picture,
do you think that the struggle
is a contingent thing?
It sounds like it's quite fragmentary,
it happens here, it happens there.
What do you think like
some interpretation,
some Marxist views development
is happening and when it gets
to a certain point, there'll be
a general obstruction
a general disruption.
It's like asking you to
predict the U.S. election,
but I'm curious how you see it moving
not whether you think
it's gonna happen one way
or the other.
How does, is it a systemic issue?
Is it a matter of necessity
as the fetishists of capital?
Think it will be but if
it's purely contingent,
it's hard to imagine that
struggles in many different
places, even if they happen all at once,
would be anything other than
absorbed one way or the other
back into capitalists strategies.
- Well, I think it's difficult
to answer this question
without bringing in the
question of organization.
Yes, in the sense that I
think what we have witnessed,
for example, over the last
20 years is for example,
big defeats yeah of the United States
and Europe in Afghanistan, in Iraq.
So there has been local
resistance that has led to
basically quite substantial defeats,
but at the same time and
these from my point of view,
or for example, the new
waves of such a struggle
in Latin America with
the pink tide and so on,
this is also a weekend impeally system
from some points of view.
So it has these factors
have enhanced the factors
of crisis in the scientists of the system
and you have Brazinski and others that say
that quite clearly.
So we have this awakening of the people
in the Global cells and this
is something we need to deal
with because it's a problem for us, right?
So we had these struggles
that have weakened the system
and in my view have
exacerbated the factors
that led to the global
economic crisis in 2008.
But at the same time what's missing here
is an international
and so I think that even
for these to then lead
to a kind of broader revolutionary
transformation globally
so we need has as latin said, Lance,
it's the subjective side
that's always the biggest problem.
- Thanks that's great.
Well, sign me up for the international
and I bet you'd have a lot
of people in the audience there too.
Maybe since there aren't
further questions.
There's another question that
I think is pretty marginal
about genetics and pathology
I don't really think that's relevant
you can answer it if you want to.
Otherwise we can thank you.
Well, here's, here's another question.
Do you want to take that one?
Do you see it.
- As the industrialization takes place,
both in the developed
and developing world,
does that affect the
disruptive potential workers
have thanks to corporation.
Does the increasing absorption of workers
by personal services sector,
underminded disruptive force?
Well, I think as I tried to
discuss the dynamics of workers,
power is complex yeah, so for example,
the industrialization and
the shift of production
we can work as in a specific area like
the industrialized area,
while at the same time can
create new centers of production
and disruption, like for example,
the shift of production to East Asia.
At the same time also the
fact that this is based
on logistics and connections and so on
can also create sources of power,
like for example of logistics struggle.
And so for example, Beverly
silver differentiate
the weakening of organized
labor at the labor market level,
or even at the association in
terms of association of power
that we have witnessed in
Europe and in the United States
over the last 40 years
but at the same time, you can
have new sources of power,
like the example of
the logistics or so on.
So this is a process that
it's a contradictory process.
I wouldn't just give a single answer.
So for example, the
answer the audience gave
about COVID-19 was quite good.
So I do think that it both weakens
and creates new sources of power.
And in terms of personal services sector,
what I think this is personnel services,
What do you mean exactly?
- Maybe the service sector in general,
which in at least from
the U.S. perspective
has become it's taken over
where industry used to be.
- Yeah, catering cab work, food services.
Well, for example, in
terms of food services
or even catering and so on,
I don't think it necessarily reduces
the power of disruption, what percent,
because for example,
services that cannot be outsourced.
So in services that cannot be outsourced,
workers can still have quite
a lot of disruptive power.
I think key to kind of longterm successes
is probably to link the struggles
also to struggles in production.
So, the people sense that
you're about to leave
and that's making them anxious
and ask really good questions.
So if you don't mind taking a couple more.
- Yes.
- So let's read out,
maybe I'll just read them out
just to the NASA or Ratko.
How do you think Engles and Marx differed
on their analysis of gender issues
and then I'll point out
Vanessa Gubbins is question.
Do you have thoughts about
the limits to accumulation?
How do you think about that limit?
What potential might it have?
And there's finally a
question about automation,
whether automation will undermine
workers' leverage globally.
That's from Michael Pulsford.
- Okay.
How do you think Anderson Mark's different
on their analysis of gender issues?
I need to think about
this social reproduction.
It's very broad.
You think about it.
- Well the first thing I would say,
I mean about this point
is that if we compare
the Marx's notebooks on
gender and the family
and Angus is origin of private property,
the family and the States so
guys, it's 11 o'clock here.
So, if we compare the two,
the first thing I would say is
that Angus had more of a kind
of evolutionist outlook while Marx
was also more interested
in the kind of persistence
of different forms of gender
relations and social relations
around the world.
For example, in pre capitalist
societies in the early 1880s.
So one thing I would highlight
about this difference,
which isn't something I have
really investigated so far
is that I think, especially in
the later years of his life,
Marx was looking much more of
the kind of differences forms
of social and gender
relations existing, globally.
Looking also at that potential in terms
of social transformation, right?
So the idea that social transformation
doesn't originate only within capitalism,
but also forms of
opposition to capitalism.
And so probably these less
evolutionistic approach
is something I would highlight about Marx,
but I haven't studied
this in great that, well.
- Maybe we should suspend now,
given how late it is there.
And zoom gives you the idea that
you can exploit people without stopping.
So maybe we should give
you a chance to rest,
but I can ask people to do whose questions
haven't been answered
yet, you send them to me,
you can find me in the
German department at Yale
and I can forward them
to professor Pradella
if that's okay with you.
- Yeah, that's all right.
- Okay, why don't we do that?
And we thank professor Pradella for
a really thought inspiring presentation.
This would be the huge
applause thunderous applause.
- Thank you.
- Okay.